everything everywhere all at once was
the breakout hit of 2022 wait was it
also the breakout hit of all things
universes and timelines I don't know I'm
gonna stick to the timeline and universe
we know and here it was a big old smash
it was anchored around the insanely fun
performance Michelle yo gave as she
moved from character to character
Universe to Universe being a general
badass so it must have been written with
her in mind right nope turns out the
directors the Daniels totes had Jackie
Chan in mind when they wrote it but when
they hit the casting phase they were
having trouble like envisioning Jackie
or any dude for that matter playing the
part and they also realized they knew
the perfect woman for it already
Michelle yo she was actually cast as a
different part in the movie already and
they said she felt like family like
their aunt they shifted gears so hard
they decided that if she said no they
might just bail on the movie altogether
no pressure Auntie Michelle just the
fate of a hit Movie in Your Hands